it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we examine the cultural stories
of the day and for that we turn to Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo who
joins me here in DC here he is Raymond
it's good to see you in studio now it
was
Grammy night you know I tried to ignore
it well what I need to know Laura it was
a rebound from previous years from the
all-time low rating of the Grammys still
they were down 5 million from 2020. wow
they tried to trot the stars out on the
red carpet the big winner of the night
of course Harry Styles looked like
Freddie Mercury at a circus then if
you've ever wondered what 1-800 Flowers
does with their returns lizzo showed us
she looked like ftd's discard pile if
you look closely
well I thought it was a tribute to
Grimace oh a little bit like oh that's
red a little well the color was awful
what was that poor um and who I always
adored Shania Twain what was she on
she's beautiful but it's gorgeous I
think she was wearing part of the Cowell
a DeVille line you know maybe
Chick-fil-A is sponsoring her tour I
don't quite know what that ensem is but
uh but look I like when the stars get
topical lore yeah Sam Smith came as the
red China spy balloon surrounded by
covet variants I thought this was very
creative because they had their own
little Spike Spike proteins there yeah
well you know the truth is the Grammy
presenters throughout the evening were
as scary as the performances themselves
the face formally known as Madonna's
made an appearance
if they call you shocking
scandalous
troublesome
problematic
provocative
or
dangerous
you are definitely on to something
that's where you make noise
you are yeah thank you that's when you
take Prevagen all right please
Jeb Bush approach well Madge introdes
Sam Smith who performed such a cliche
song Oh God Unholy yeah yo you know and
what full shot number What followed the
number Laura was almost as grotesque is
the thing itself watch this
Grammy Awards is sponsored by Pfizer
you can't make that up we did not edit
that it literally said right after that
performance sponsored by Pfizer from the
people that brought you myocarditis the
devil ladies and gentlemen I mean who
came up with that idea but poor this guy
you know it's the mark of the desperate
Entertainer when they have to go back to
The Well of Satanism to get attention I
mean he's like a plus-sized Marilyn
Manson at this point you know you gotta
give it a rest you tell them something
Ozzy Osbourne did it better okay if
you're if this is your thing like Ozzy
rock well back in the 70s when the
culture is this depraved this stuff
loses its ability to shock uh Jill Biden
Laura made a surprise appearance at the
Grammys as a presenter at first I
thought she might be announcing best
audio performance of a classified
document but she did have that big
crossover Latin hit you remember that a
few years oh yeah so say it with me see
say Broadway the future is ours so say
it with me
[Music]
the future is ours see surprise way that
was a great song that was a great one
the club's ball playing at night
she got a kind of a limp reception yes
she did
thank you it's the first winner of the
recording Academy's best song for social
change to share being ajapur
foreign
ER for his stirring song baroye
[Applause]
she's well she's slaughtered Spanish
Let's Go Slaughter another language why
do they keep putting the first lady in
this position where she's having to put
foreign words in foreign languages in
her mouth it's obviously uncomfortable
well Raymond
I sort of missed it when they invited
Melania to come present an award right
well only Michelle Obama appeared at the
grammy so first of all Melania would
look gorgeous up there I mean Joe Biden
looked pretty she wasn't invited as a
programming note we will be back with
you tomorrow night coverage of the State
of the Union but the president is hard
at work prepping he tweeted out this
picture he's rehearsing note the milk
and cookies Laura I think that you'll
see it in a second it'll come up you
tweeted there it is I think what they're
telling him is what if you stop saying
no joke we're going to bring out the
Oreos God's honest truth Raymond Arroyo
I'm working hard with my red pen wait Mr
President that's blue oh it's it's red
oh they just blew
um all right Raymond so tomorrow night
tomorrow night midnight again the coffee
or the Margaritas all right Raymond
thank you great to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else